have you ever picked up a movie in a
store glancing at the talent involved
only to realize you've never even heard
of it before
perhaps you decided to watch said film
only to find yourself perplexed to the
point of annoyance strange editing
choices plagued your OCD flat seemingly
emotionless performances caused a
disconnect with the characters and your
attention wandered until you began
focusing on Ewan McGregor's curiously hi
pant legs that was my experience with
stay a film released in the fall of 2005
starring Ewan McGregor Naomi Watts and
Ryan Gosling it was directed by Marc
Forster who at the time was mostly known
for monsters ball in Finding Neverland
it was written by David Benioff who had
written the novel and screenplay for
25th hour and the screenplay for Troy
and he since become more recognized as
one of the primary creative forces
behind Game of Thrones the film only
grossed about three million dollars
domestically and was tossed out of
theaters in a couple weeks with stay I
found myself watching the film and
snippets over the course of a few days
because it just wasn't gripping me I
genuinely didn't care for it
and then it ended and the rug was pulled
out from beneath me and without even
thinking about it I instantly began
watching the film a second time with a
vastly different outlook everything had
changed and I was convinced I was
watching a forgotten gem buried deep
within the bargain bins at Best Buy for
the past 11 years in 2005 stay debuted
to crushingly awful reviews according to
Rotten Tomatoes only 27% of critics
positively reviewed it with an average
rating of four point six out of ten from
all those reviews I've seen a phrase
drifting around the film community for
many years usually spouted off by
someone defending a film they loved
against an onslaught of bad reviews they
just didn't get it
generally in most cases I find that to
be a load of crap if you liked a movie
cool
if you
cool more power to you it simply doesn't
have an effect on me but in the case of
stay as I began reading through these
reviews I actually do feel that many
critics back in oh five honestly didn't
get it the entire film works you just
have to think Thank You Fox
hey movies that require people to sit
back and think about what they've just
seen are often unpopular with audiences
many people would just like to go to the
movies to have fun and would rather not
leave the theater confuse about what
they just watched this is common and
most film buffs have all had an
experience where they've just seen an
impactful artistic film and find
themselves the only person present
defending it from an onslaught of hate
it's an entirely different beast with
film critics I personally love to be
challenged by a film I can easily become
fascinated with a difficult movie and
find myself re watching key scenes over
and over trying to come up with my own
theories but not all critics are like
that
some critics don't appreciate being
challenged by a film because this almost
insults them words like pretentious get
thrown around a lot to describe such
films because no one likes to feel dumb
but I don't find stay pretentious in the
least to me that term is useful to
describe films that seem to be talking
down to you as if the director and
writer are perched on their ivory tower
overseeing all the lowly commoners
attending their art piece stay is
nothing like that it's simply a smart
and clever film one ballsy enough to
risk alienating its audience almost
completely upon first viewing to be fair
not all critics loathed stay one in
particular saw something special in the
film Roger Ebert gave it
three-and-a-half out of four stars and
published a review that actually
discussed the filmmaking on display
rather than tossing together a few
insulting $5 words because that's just
what film critics do right
I think Ebert was very wise here because
over the years stay has developed a
small but passionate
fanbase and I hope this video sheds some
light on the film and encourages more
people to seek it out and decades past
if a film opened to poor reviews it had
the ability to gain new life on home
video or as more people saw it and
examined it in the 60s when many critics
dismissed 2001 a Space Odyssey as here
comes that word again
pretentious Ebert was also one of the
few who got it right we know today that
it's a masterpiece of science fiction
and a very prophetic film even a film
like predator one of the best action
movies ever made got poor reviews
initially and has since become a classic
once again
Ebert got it right these films have
found their audience today but there's
something neither of them had to deal
with in doing so a majority opinion
today the Internet has given us things
like Rotten Tomatoes IMDB likes retweets
subscribers and followers we give
numbers a great amount of value and in
some ways we absolutely should
but today once a film has been assigned
a consensus amongst audiences it seems
the film is doomed to forever carry that
with it and a movie like stay has been
crushed beneath the weight of that for
11 years when I grew up I discovered the
Sandlot because I rented it from the
library I wanted to see it and so I saw
it and I've always loved it ever since
but if rotten tomatoes had existed back
in the 90s I may have looked it up seen
its rating and thought twice about
renting it I think you get my point
films that receive negative reviews
receive negative press then people begin
to feel comfortable hating it and a
majority opinion rules does stay deserve
the reaction it got let's examine the
film from beginning to end and be warned
this will be spoiler filled so I
encourage you to watch the film if you
haven't already then return to this
point in the video the film opens with a
brilliantly staged POV car crash ending
on an upwards angle of the Brooklyn
Bridge Henry Letham played by Gosling
appears to be casually sitting by this
disaster as if he was the cause
of it an abrupt cut morphs Henry's face
into our main character Sam played by
McGregor
he awakes in bed curiously grasping a
wedding ring pay close attention to the
paintings behind Sam they're important
we transition again to Sam on a bicycle
heading to work where we meet Lila
played by watts Sam tells her their
neighbors baby kept him up all night our
neighbors don't have a baby she tells
him but Sam vanishes from the area
before the conversation can get much
farther upon first viewing these moments
feel awkward and flat and the editing
comes off showy and pointless next Henri
meets Sam who first tells him that it's
going to hail
despite sunny weather before retracting
realizing that his regular therapist
isn't there this is the first time I
began to notice that Gosling was the
only actor truly putting in 110% on my
first viewing I found myself
disappointed in the performance is given
by McGregor and Watts and continuously
drawn to goslings magnetic work having
seen the film four times now I know this
wasn't a mistake nor was this McGregor
and Watts sleepwalking through their
roles more on this later in this scene
we learned that Henry is majoring in
fine art and that he feels deeply guilty
about a car accident the editing here is
purposefully unconventional with cuts
inter spliced with characters on the
same side of the frame this is rare as
editing and film is commonly designed to
keep the eye moving from side to side
thus keeping our attention but this also
isn't a mistake this is by design Henry
leave saying he wants to get home before
the hail starts and we pan left to
salmon lila talking the filmmakers
denying us our traditional cutaway to an
establishing shot this is the first
scene that we get a look at Sam's
curiously high pant legs this wasn't due
to poor costume design it actually
reoccurs throughout the entire film lila
tears up her drawing of sam declaring it
and we are shown that lila has once
attempted suicide also just as henry
predicted
Hales next we get a quick insert of a
woman in a car and then a scene where
Henry puts out a cigarette on his arm
pay close attention to the passengers on
this train the Train doors open and out
walks Lila except now she's in her
apartment she expresses even more doubt
about her future as an artist fearing
that no one will remember her then Henri
meets Sam again inquiring about the
wedding ring and the painting in his
office in a random moment he admits he
can no longer understand the whither man
Henry then admits to hearing voices and
he explains what they're saying I didn't
move am I not supposed to move on I
can't watch anymore
stay with me
but they're interrupted by Sam's friend
remember this guy's face here we're
reminded again about Henry's terrible
guilt in fact we learned that he wants
to kill himself in three days directly
after this scene a woman is shown at a
mental hospital screaming okay now let
go after visiting a friend to inform him
that his patient may attempt suicide
Sam is counting Lila's pills then
another abrupt cut has Sam jump from one
side of the room to another
after a quick conversation about Henry's
suicidal nature the water from the
bathtub begins to reflect on the window
before we cut away to the bathtub next
we see Henry at an art lecture while he
becomes aware that he's being watched
overhead by Sam upon leaving Sam is now
curiously on the next floor down having
somehow teleported there they discussed
the art pieces around them and then the
room is overtaken by twins and triplets
no explanation is given for this and to
be honest on my first viewing I didn't
even notice Henry now says the reason he
wants to kill himself on Saturday is
because it's his 21st birthday we also
learn here that Henry's parents have
passed away the scene continues and
their conversation plays out over
multiple cuts that are actually showing
the same angle yet the position of the
characters is shifting then they walk
past a pillar emerging from the opposite
side they walk past another and Sam has
switched sides with Henry he talks about
a girl he wanted to marry named Athena
he says he bought her a ring that looks
just like the one Sam was holding
earlier he says she is gone and then
we're almost instantly in an aquarium
where two people say
not going to make it then we travel
through the water back to Sam and Lila
and take note of the sound of a baby
crying this could be mistaken for the
walrus on first viewing but it is
absolutely a baby in this scene we
learned that Lila has stopped taking her
meds
harkening back to Sam earlier counting
her pills she says she can't paint on
meds and another abrupt cut occurs again
we hear a baby crying in the background
before the scene ends Lila calls Sam by
the name Henry take note of the fact
that they're on the 21st floor then we
meet Leon Patterson played by Bob
Hoskins one of Sam's friends who is
blind they share a chess match while
Leon recounts a tale about a young boy
wishing his father would wake up because
he's burning it's a tale recounted by
Sigmund Freud commonly referred to as
the burning child or the burning boy
it's about a father who dreams his child
is burning and wakes to find it actually
happening but the child is attempting to
wake his father up because his father
doesn't notice that he's on fire Henry
suddenly appears only to be greatly
taken aback by Leon's presence and later
says that's his father even though he's
positive his father is actually dead
brief inserts of Leon dead are shown
here as well as a flash of a family
photo
he continues to suffer with the belief
that he's responsible for their deaths
he then says in troubles will cease
unfortunate smiling and then we get an
insert of Lila's face
turning into Athena's saying the words
yes
Henry this is one of the most important
parts of the entire movie for
deciphering the film's structure after
being chased through a maze of stairs
Sam investigates Henry's apartment where
he finds the words forgive me written
across the walls an answering machine
plays the voice of Sam saying Henry
listen
stay with me okay listen to my voice
heavily next a boy approaches Henry
asking his mother mommy is having aa
nine while eating Chinese food Sam and
Lila discuss Henry's favorite artist who
just so happened to have killed himself
on his 21st birthday
then Lila describes in gruesome detail
how she attempted to end her life once
before opening a fortune cookie reciting
these words your troubles will cease and
fortune will smile upon you soon were
thrown through multiple cuts as Sam
jumps from one location to the next very
rapidly calling Henry's former therapist
Beth who says Beth and 9s must back
while approaching Beth a baby is heard
crying again she once again recites the
words I didn't touch him I know you're
not supposed to move them and suggests
that Sam visit Henry's mother who's
supposed to be dead outside the car
window we transitioned from city to
country instantly and Sam is already on
the porch as he's leaving the car if you
weren't curious already about the film
structure this is where things get
really nuts the house is empty safe for
the mother and the dog she randomly
states that she's been alone in the
house for 1,000 years she begins to
express that she feels hated and
unwanted and the edits get even more
aggressive
she believes that Sam is Henry her son
she states that Henry loved to go to the
zoo to watch the walrus swim with no
explanation she begins to believe from
her head while saying she knows he
didn't mean to harm anyone the dog
attacks Sam and then we're in a room I
don't want to call it a hospital or a
doctor's office because it seems
purposefully different than that there's
also a very old phone on the wall that
just seems out of place the sheriff
shows up to tell us that Henry's mom has
been long dead and there's no way he
could have been talking with her then
Henry visits a strip club and with no
explanation images from his past begin
playing on a screen their family photos
images of the Brooklyn Bridge even an
image of a boy watching a man
at the zoo we're reminded here of the
incredible guilt he feels from something
he's done at this point the cuts in the
film began to grow even stranger henry
appears at Sam's house more confusion
abounds as Henry tries to comprehend how
his parents could possibly be alive
notice the door number they stand in
front of when their argument breaks out
the characters begin reciting each
other's dialogue even switching places
momentarily they have a sobering
conversation about suicide before Henry
pulls a gun on Sam admitting to killing
his parents Sam then ventures into the
city searching for Athena the girl that
Henry wanted to propose to he eventually
catches a break when a waitress tells
him where to find Athena this waitress
is played by the same woman from the
mental hospital earlier Sam finds Athena
practicing her lines from an upcoming
play of Hamlet understanding the story
of Hamlet is very important to
understanding the story of stay perhaps
the most famous scene from Hamlet is the
to be or not to be scene in which Hamlet
muses about suicide and death and
whether or not living with pain is
better than dying and ending it all
interestingly Gosling's character is
named Henry Letham which is an anagram
of Hamlet Athena recounts her knowledge
of Henry which as she says it involves
an odd feeling that she's known him from
somewhere before a feeling that sam
seems to share she says she'll take Sam
to an art book store that Henry likes
and leads him down a flight of stairs
before completely vanishing causing Sam
to fall down the staircase images of
Henry's past flash before our eyes and
Sam travels back up again to find the
exact same scene playing out for him
again the next sequence with Henry and
his father is easily one of the
strangest in the entire film which again
does make sense and I'll discuss it
later
Henry begs his father to look at him and
actually see him and touches him causing
his father to regain his eyesight his
father stares at Henry as if he's seeing
him for the first time we then get
another flash of the car crash revealing
that Athena Henry and both of his
parents were
in the car when the accident occurred
Sam finds the bookstore that Henry
enjoyed going to that has his paintings
hung up the owner of the shop also
happens to be the same older man on the
train earlier who then asks Sam if Henry
has what it takes to really make it as
an artist we transition to Henry exiting
a bus watching Athena at a dance class
through the window unable to go to her
next Lila is hanging one of Henry's
paintings and Sam calls her discovering
that Henry's favorite artist killed
himself on the Brooklyn Bridge Liane
shows up proclaiming that the world is
an illusion and Lila runs to the
Brooklyn Bridge after discovering that
all her paintings are Henry's in a blink
and you'll miss it moment at the bottom
of the staircase lies a punctured tire
and a broken headlight Henry has now
seen contemplating wedding jewelry when
the boy returns to ask again his head
then begins to bleed like his mother's
earlier and the entire city stops to
look at him
this is when Henry starts to connect
things and blurs by Sam on opposite
trains Sam runs for the bridge past
artwork with Henry's face on it as the
very atmosphere around them begins to
move and shudder Sam and Henry meet each
other on the bridge Henry tell Sam that
he's real but he knows Sam is just
trying to save him but he's too late
this dialog works for what Sam believes
is the truth in this moment and for what
the film is actually about Henry puts
the gun into his mouth and shoots and we
are now on the bridge with Sam kneeling
over Henry trying to revive him Beth now
appears saying she was the first one on
the scene repeating these lines I have
her right in front of me it was right in
front of me I was the first one here I
didn't
I know you have a phone Lila shows up
and watches Henry while Sam declares
that Henry's girlfriend and parents are
dead in the car behind them Lila and Sam
appear here to be meeting for the first
time as a crowd gathers around Henry
we learned that Lila is a nurse and Sam
is a doctor he finds Henry's wallet and
a wedding ring falls out Henry thinks
the light streaming above him is Hale he
asks them to forgive him we hear a baby
crying in a car and Henry reaches for
the wedding ring a woman appears
regretfully saying he's just a kid then
that boy reappears saying mom is heaven
in the movies most heartbreaking scene
Henry mistakes Lila for Athena asking
her to marry him
she agrees understanding what's really
happening to Henry here a man on the
street says he's not going to make it
Henry begins to fade and is put on a
stretcher we pan up to see the top of
the Brooklyn Bridge the film seems to
suggest that Henry is still taking in
his surroundings despite the fact that
his body has shut down and he is likely
dead or very close to it
just before Sam and Lila agreed to get
coffee flashes from earlier events are
seen and as we rise upwards
take note of the number on top of the
ambulance so what the hell did we just
see a rather brilliant piece of
filmmaking the easiest way to describe
this film is to break down the story
into two parts things that actually
occurred and things that were in Henry's
mind the events that actually occurred
are as follows
Henry Athena and his parents get into a
terrible car accident on the Brooklyn
Bridge after his tire blows out Henry is
the only one who survives but only for a
brief while a woman named Beth is the
first person on the scene but Sam a
doctor soon arrives to care for Henry
and Lila a nurse shows up as well as
Henry fades he hears that everyone he
loved is
in the car behind them and he asks Lila
to marry him thinking she's actually
Athena due to his severe head trauma
Henry dies and Sam and Lila agreed to
get coffee together because neither of
them feel they'll be able to sleep
everything else in the film can be
attributed to a lucid dream state or
hallucination that Henry was having as
he lay on the pavement dying this is why
so many odd purposeful continuity errors
occurred in the film and white character
suddenly appeared in places with no real
explanation of how they arrived there
when we dream do we ever really remember
how we got somewhere or are we suddenly
just there so let's look at the film
differently now that we know the truth
Sam is really just an imagined version
of the doctor that's kneeling above
Henry into opening Henry's paintings are
clearly visible behind Sam in his
apartment and Sam is already grasping
Henry's wedding ring in the film Sam had
complained about a baby crying keeping
him up all night this is because of the
baby crying in the car across from Henry
as he dies the same baby is heard
throughout Henry's dream multiple times
because the baby cries throughout the
entirety of Henry's death in the real
world
also as stated earlier it seemed like
Henry was the only character with
well-rounded emotion of any kind with
Gosling giving the best performance and
McGregor and Watts feeling oddly flat
this is because this is Henry's dream
and he knows himself the best these two
people he's manifesting in his brain are
just that manifestations false
representations of actual people this is
why the film connects the most with
Henry's character in the first scene
where Sam meets Henry he's taken aback
by the absence of his former therapist
Beth wondering why Sam has replaced her
this is because in the real world Beth
was the first woman on the scene of the
accident who was later replaced with Sam
who tries to help Henry Henry also
commented that it was going to Hale
because as he lay on the
dying he believes he sees hail falling
from the sky in Henry's dream
Lila is an artist facing a lot of
self-doubt tell me I'm good you're good
tell me they'll remember me
she has once attempted suicide and
believes all her work to be
Henry is dreaming Lila this way because
this is how he likely feels there are
many references to Henry making it as an
artist and doubt on whether or not he's
good enough so what do you think is he
gonna make it
I think he's got what it takes it's also
likely that Henry has attempted suicide
in the past and is using the characters
inhabiting his dream to work through his
own inner demons in the real world as
bystanders gather around Henry's dying
body they begin to inhabit his dream as
well the man on the train and the
bookstore is simply a man observing the
accident scene the crazy lady in the
hospital and the waitress repeats her
lines as well
virtually every character within Henry's
dream is gathered around his body on the
bridge there was also a scene earlier in
which Henry randomly declared he no
longer understands the weatherman to me
this scene served as a hilarious
reminder of how funny our dreams can be
when we explained them to people have
you ever had such a weird dream that you
laugh as you explain it to someone
imagine explaining that you just dreamt
that you could no longer understand the
weatherman I know I've certainly had
strange dreams like that Henry also told
Sam here that he is hearing voices and
he tells him what they are these voices
are simply the words spoken by the
people that are surrounding him on the
bridge as he fades as Henry's dream
plays on the editing in the film gets
more and more odd and as stated this was
on purpose as Henry is dying on the
bridge his brain cells are also dying
he's beginning to lose his battle to
stay alive and his hallucinatory dream
state grows worse as his dream begins to
cave in on itself this is why the
editing grows more
more confusing as the film goes on after
Henry says he wants to kill himself on
his 21st birthday the number 21 begins
showing up everywhere in the film and we
learn of the guilt that Henry is feeling
as he dies this is why the words forgive
me permeate many moments of his dream as
he dies he feels tremendous guilt for
being the one driving the car during the
accident when we are shown Henry
observing the manatees at the zoo this
is a reminder of his childhood love of
the aquarium which his mother mentions
as well we're even shown a quick flash
of a photo of this when Henry's past is
shown in the strip club scene next we
met Leon Henry's dad who in his dream is
blind why was this this is likely
because Henry doesn't feel appreciated
or even noticed by his father perhaps
Henry's father takes no note of his
son's art and Henry is hurt by this
this theory is strengthened by the tale
of the burning boy that his father
recites about a boy who was burning
trying to wake his father who isn't
noticing this would also explain the
scene in which Henry forcibly makes his
father's sight return he wants his
father to see him for who he really is
he wants his father to open his eyes
this makes perfect sense because dreams
are often our way of obtaining something
we don't have in reality or exploring
some hidden emotions that we've locked
away after Henry discovers his father is
in his dream he flips out and the scene
ends with a shot of Athena saying
this gives us a major clue this tells us
that at this point in reality Henry has
just asked Lila to marry him thinking
that she is actually Athena henry is
truly beginning to fade here and at this
point in the dream the world of his
dream begins crumbling even more because
of this clue we can easily decipher the
timeline of what is happening in the
real world
while Henry is dreaming when Lila is
describing her attempt at suicide it's
likely because this is what Henry once
tried to do as well and he's using this
dream to work through his desire to keep
living after visiting Beth who in
reality is simply the first woman on the
scene of this accident Henry's dream
gets even more jumbled as he nears death
Sam meets Henry's mother who begins
bleeding out from her head wound that
Henry is likely imagining she has the
presence of Henry's childhood dog is
probably simply there due to Henry
recalling the past when Sam meets Athena
she mentions feeling like she's known
Henry for a long time a feeling Sam
seems to acknowledge being that they are
simply subjects of Henry's subconscious
this makes perfect sense the following
sequence where Henry falls down a flight
of stairs is likely a tribute to all of
those falling dreams we've all had
before the scene where Henry is watching
Athena dance I believe is due to the
painful realization that Henry has as he
dies that he can never see her again
that there's absolutely nothing he can
do they are forever separated and he
can't go to her when Lila and Sam
discovered that Henry's favorite artist
killed himself on the Brooklyn Bridge
they both raced to get there I mentioned
one specific moment where a punctured
tire and a headlight lay at the bottom
of the stairs
this is likely pieces of the car
wreckage that Henry has inserted into
his dream as Henry stands before the
wedding jewelry he begins to bleed out
in front of people the same people who
are standing over his dying body a
realization is setting in he's dreaming
this happens to many of us in our dreams
that moment when we realize we are
dreaming is usually right before we wake
up as Henry nears death in the real
world
world of his dream begins to fade as the
cinematography makes clear and Henry
kills himself forcing himself out of his
hallucinatory state because if you've
seen inception you know dying in a dream
forces you to wake up now we see all of
these moments connect and make sense
Henry imagined a world in which he
attempted to work through his last
remaining feelings guilt and unrequited
love that of a girl and that of his
parents the people in his dream like Sam
and Lila are simply manifestations of
his own life and feelings he uses them
to work through his demons the most
confusing aspect of the movie for me is
the very end when sam asks lila for
coffee a few inserts of the dream appear
here this could be because Henry's brain
is still operating as his body fully
dies but that would seem to indicate
that even this specific moment is a
dream to be completely honest I'm still
a little unsure of the meaning of this
moment there is an alternate theory that
Henry planned to kill Athena and his
parents on the bridge recreating what
his favorite artist had done on his
birthday I don't believe this to be true
for one Henry feels an incredible amount
of guilt and constantly asks for
forgiveness but the main reason I don't
give this theory any merit is because we
are shown Henry's tire blowout this is
not something a depressed college
student plans this was clearly an
accident so what the hell was with Sam's
pants why are they purposefully too
short in every scene the answer is
simple what happens to trousers when you
kneel down the legs ride up
Henry's view of Sam on the bridge is of
him crouching down over him so in every
moment of Henry's dream Sam's pants look
like that damn
so his stay really the muddled contrived
and pretentious art house BS that
critics exclaimed it to be 11 years ago
not even remotely this is an extremely
smart film with an absurd amount of
creativity and thought behind it it is
that rare film that perhaps shouldn't
even be reviewed until seen a second
time is it an unseen forgotten
masterpiece time will tell but it's
certainly a film worth revisiting guys I
hope you like my in-depth analysis of
stay if you feel this film deserves more
note share this video around maybe show
it to people who didn't appreciate the
movie maybe show it to somebody who does
like the movie I don't know I'm just
saying stay deserves more attention you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes